[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
i did conan a few times and one time
i was sitting on the couch and it was
like we were coming back from a break
and andy richter's sitting next to me
and he goes he looks down he goes are
you wearing gucci shoes
and i go yeah he goes you know you still
like you you know you still look like
you run a bowling alley
the only reason for me to get a nicer
car as i go on if i do start getting
like really really fancy cars is because
when i die in them yeah you want to die
in a cool car yes you don't want to die
in a sad car that car outside yeah you
die in that dude that you're on so
so sick like mclaren's main page website
tom died in this like my kids will be
like have you seen this photo of my dad
it's pretty crazy by the way they and
some news sources don't have a photo of
you so they they superimpose the
basketball photo of you inside the
vehicle like that
but by the way
that meme is already done
it's already done it's insane no dude uh
this is actually sad but
earlier it was last year um some kid in
a mclaren
[__] drove into and it was on bert
street
it was honestly
it could have been he takes his shirt
off he's like
right into a [__] light post
first the first on the news he's like
dude it was [__] sick
he didn't really know me but i was like
hey man
he knows me now dude oh yeah he knew you
for that second for sure the kid clipped
a mclaren on his road yeah or like at
the intersect like intersection down i
think it was in a 570 or a 610 either
way too fast i've seen two like i've
seen a number of wild like accidents
after yeah but i've seen two things
happen before like live live oh [__] one
was that these cars were
racing like just coming up 95 in the
from west palm beach go heading north
and i'm like oh man these guys are
flying and it's night so there's like
not a lot of cars on the road right and
they're dude i mean when they passed
this had to be doing over 100 you know
right i was like holy [__] and then you
know the the road kind of turns then
you're going straight and i saw
lights
like go up in the air
and then go away and then come back and
i was like oh
somebody hit a vehicle and sent it up in
the air and it did a flip holy [__] and
then we pull up and it's sitting on its
roof holy [__] and we pull over and run
out there and it's on 95. i mean it's
it's a crazy highway that's running out
too yeah and we just look in and there's
people like laying around i was like you
guys are all gonna die man
it's [__] i was gonna say it's
[__] stevo and he's like yeah dude
once we were in florida i never did yard
work hmm i know what kind of equipment
were you riding in uh
i remember we had the push and then in
that milwaukee house with the that uh my
dad went and got the riding mower john
deere what was it i don't remember the
craftsman could have been a craftsman if
it was a deer you'd know it yeah i don't
know you never forget a deer tom
riding that thing around what are you
talking about you're right yeah
i would remember yeah you remember come
on everyone remember that was the green
and i was [__] i gotta say i was
thrilled to be doing that i liked it
before you could drive and like they had
like [__] horses
it was pretty like substantial like it
wasn't enormous amount of land but it
took a while to get out there
did you ever joyride the riding lawn
mower off the property
that's a bad luck a little bit but not
not not falling down a little bit didn't
go to the circle
there was a nazi across the street i
forgot that
you should open with that i know what
are you doing talking about your tennis
courts it took me a while to put it
together you know he was like 90 and
german and the flag didn't give it away
and i [__] you know i really click
with this guy
did you ever grow up in an area where
people were slipping on ice yes i lived
in the midwest that to me the slipping
on the ice might be because when you
slip on ice is hilarious yes and deadly
yes but funny before dead yes
the best part is when you slip it's that
when you hit the apex and you almost
freeze for a second
that's my favorite i've eaten [__] on
ice
so many times
seriously yeah oh my god nothing hurts
more the time that you actually do it is
when you're like
you're distracted you're like oh all
right we gotta go and you just walk out
the door like you normally would and you
don't realize that there's an ice patch
either on those stairs on the sidewalk
and you will with force and momentum
yeah i mean
just absolutely eat [__] it's funny to
watch but like i know a dude who died he
slipped on the ice hit his head and he
died uh freshman year college yeah
what he was a freshman he was a freshman
in college
no he's not he's dead now
right he's
not
anymore
remember when you were a freshman in
college
[Laughter]
not
anymore have you ever thought about
some girl in maybe college right now but
still have a t-shirt that you nutted on
oh t-buns when he nutted here
[Applause]
at 96 96.
it's my favorite shirt
you got to be kidding me why [__]
kept the nut on the shirt that's so
crazy though and then the nut just hangs
out and stays it's just like i'm just
going to chill here yeah test me three
four years but i'll still be good like
what yeah but i mean that happens with
like the super famous because drake had
that thing the hot sauce and the rubber
yeah
that's a good move though yeah i mean if
you really
if you know you're being targeted but
also to have to think about something at
that level that's crazy yeah you and i
well you're married but even if you
weren't the combined will never know the
amount of [__] that's floating that
guy's [__] way drake's yeah and to
have to [__]
put hot sauce in my condom
after i [__] yeah i mean the
so the story was that
he knew
he knows that he's a target of women who
want to get pregnant by him
and he like you said he has his choice
every day and every night all day long
yeah all day of like
girls who are super hot and in clubs
globally yeah globally globally
uh so that when his 747 touches down
then he goes to a function
he's just like hurt
her and so anyways they all they all
want him but he thinks now of the fact
that like you know
they see getting pregnant by him as like
a life achievement
so he started to put
hot sauce like when he would take off
his condom
and throw it in a trash can
he would pour hot sauce in there
to kill the sperm kill the sperm and
also like if this
woman would try to
put it in her
because like that actually happens
that you know she would have she would
have a little surprise like that though
i guess possibly probably
out of a condom and then
fingering yourself with it i mean i mean
it's going to make that he's gone [__]
go wow yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
like when she grabs how do you know you
know what i mean like if you're if you
got a condom and you're taking your
fingers and you're squeezing it on your
[__] and all of a sudden it starts
burning your [__]
what makes you think hot sauce i don't
think so i think she probably started
screaming one of them
and
and he was probably in bed like yeah you
got that hot sauce [__] huh
put a little cholula on that one for you
you got that tapatio [__]
all right
started screaming that [__] to her
i should [__] yeah
oh my god
i thought i was gonna have your baby
drake two years later we moved to
milwaukee he became the manager of the
milwaukee branch okay then we stayed
there from uh
let's see we moved there when i was 11
we left and i was halfway through my
freshman year in high school my dad
would not let me
we would not move the family until
football season was over he's like you
cannot quit on the team that's crazy
i'm a [__] freshman in high school
dude so like yeah he was like this is
like a war announcement like you will
not abandon the [__] troops
go out there and do your workouts and
you shut up we went one and nine yeah
anyway
yeah
the season ended and then he allowed the
freshman football freshman football
jesus christ he's like you can't quit
he's a man of honor yeah so we moved to
vero beach florida from there okay and
that's what halfway through my freshman
year in high school and then they stayed
there i finished high school there um
and then um
you were the new kid rolling in yeah
that was the shittiest move oh that
happened because midway through freshman
year in high school you feel like you're
established and everything is like
yourself
everything and you got to start over
again that one sucked the most everybody
thought you were a narc probably not
kidding also this [__] face is kind
of police like sure like his dad was an
fbi agent i got it in the [__] here
bald you got a full beard
i did i had a beard and paper everyone
later told me they're like
when you would say like where like where
are you the party like there's nobody i
don't know what you're talking about
you're walking around in a sport coat
yeah they're like we thought you were
like 23. i was 14.
i mean i did i had facial hair i was a
pretty big kid sure so they're like
there's no way this kid's freshman
that's cool also you don't really have a
backstory you were constantly moving
like where'd you come from i was in uh
you know
minneapolis my mom's peruvian sure blue
eyes sir
sure you've ever done drugs at a party
with someone that does so they do so
much that you're like
how are they still so level and they did
so much more than me no i know joey diaz
yeah
yeah dude you're like how can you it
almost makes me feel like you he didn't
take the dose because you're like
there's no way i i but the funny thing
is one time i've said it before but like
i've done edibles with joey where i'm
like i'm i feel like i'm definitely
gonna commit suicide oh dude bad idea
and
and then i go so do you like i'm like
did you not get [__] up and he's like
i had three panic attacks i'm like oh so
like he oh he likes that but he likes
going i know another guy who has you
know those guys that like have
devices like apparatus like they they
build things to smoke weed out of it you
don't just like it's cute you can't just
light it on fire so it's a whole system
and like there's heat and i pull a valve
and something lowers down you're like
this is to smoke weed
and this dude had this thing and i took
one hit and i was like [__] freaking
out right and i was like that was
horrible yeah and i asked him i was like
yeah the thing is i uh i guess you don't
feel that panic he goes no no i do and i
i look to go there i want to go there so
you want to feel panicked that's a sick
person yeah man they make a rube rude
goldberg machine to smoke weed it's like
a a car hits a marble it's a bowling
ball a bullet and then it lights and
fling and then lights light up and then
the right music kicks on they're like
now you can take a knife in and then you
take it
and you're like dude we could have just
smoked a little bit of a joint and
walked and they'll get mad by the way
they get mad at you mocking what they do
100 they're like sorry we have fun
[Laughter]
i mean it's fun man it's just a little
excessive you ever go to uh uh an
instagram page and you're like okay
pictures of weed pictures of joints
pictures of you hi
this is just who you are that's all you
are that's what you are yeah okay unless
you're unless you're funny about it like
yeah do you know who dab and granny is
mm-hmm oh bro
dab and granny is this woman you need to
see her i love her she's hilarious oh
she's like grandma that smokes
she does dabs oh she does dabs all day
long and you know the intensity of dabs
yeah yeah right like the concentration
this woman is so funny to me she's cool
we've connected on instagram before and
she's really cool but like look i mean
she is a senior citizen who can outrip
anybody i would love to see her versus
joey diaz yeah
she and she's cool she's like
she's like hey what's up actually i feel
like it's joey with a wig
dude
totally his body language
[Laughter]
it is totally so she does it but dude
she'll do this she'll post
i mean tell me i'm wrong look at how
many times oh my god
and what she's never even oh it's no big
deal and then she'll do a post video
right now
a little little cough and then she hits
it again yeah okay
and she's just ripped she's like that
was awesome see you later [__]
on this fully loaded thing you're
definitely going to throw it out i know
and then diaz is there and big j and uh
diaz is going to give you guys all
[__] stars you know i can't [__] with
that [__] dude
you know what he'll do he'll do that
he'll be like what are you a [__]
momo and then he'll he'll be like you're
not going to do it [__]
yeah it's looking like a little chicken
and then he'll like he'll cut a corner
off eat that okay and you'll be like all
right and then an hour later you'll be
like
have you done that with him yeah dude
i can't do that dude freak out so i did
his uh podcast like i don't know how
many like seven eight years ago
and he's like eat one of these i'm like
no and he's like why not i'm like
because it's [__] 800 milligrams yeah
yeah so he cuts a corner off like i'm
telling you he's like eat that
and i'm like all right like this
literally it's like you could put it
between these two little things
you know it tastes like you're eating a
crumb of a cookie or something right so
i'm like this is fine i sit there we do
the podcast like this by the end of it
i'm like
and i don't realize how [__] up i am
right i'm like all right good to see you
man
i go downstairs i have my
car
out front
i get on i put on the the directions and
it's like make a right onto the freeway
and i drive straight and i was like oh
[__] it was like it was right there
so i go all right i'll turn around so i
turn around and now it says make a left
on the freeway i drive past it again i'm
like [__] oh boy so then i turn
around again and as i'm pulling up to
that entrance i'm just i mean i'm not
doing anything wrong but i look to my
left and it's lapd and i'm like like
panicked you know oh yeah so i instead
of turning on the freeway i'm like don't
get on the freeway you're too [__] up
i just go straight i pull on to ventura
which is like the big street in the in
the valley
i pull into a ralph's parking lot
and i just put the car in park and i'm
like [__]
and i just turn my head to the right and
in the car next to me
looking at me like this is dice
no way yes i swear to god and i'm like
and i feel like you know i'm tripping
right now yeah yeah
and i'm like there's no way i can drive
right there's no [__] way i can drive
so i call an uber and
the you left your car you left my car at
the raft wow and i'm so [__] up that
like first of all the uber driver is a
woman which is pretty like kind of rare
i guess
and i'm like i'm cool don't worry she's
like what
i'm like i'm like yeah there's no way i
could do this right now i keep telling
her i'm like there's no way i could do
this she was like okay i'm like because
i'm like super [__] up and she's like
great
and i just keep repeating it to her yeah
i'm like yeah you know i was like just
all the turns you made there's no way i
could handle it she's like
all right man like meanwhile diaz is
doing his taxes he's not even facing
he's fine and he also ate like three ah
yeah and what he would do is he would
you know find him he would do the
pockets he would talk at you
for like
70 minutes right and then i was robbing
this guy
literally i got so many messages don't
take the drugs oh dude i got all the i
got all those messages don't take the
drugs like all right he talks so much
and you actually feel like you're like
at a show or something right yeah you're
listening to it right and then like
you're so like kind of mesmerized by all
the wild [__] and then he's like what's
going on with you and you're like after
that
and then i'm like i don't know i uh i
just you know i have a book out and then
you look at him he's like
oh yeah he's like zonked we know what's
crazy is that like you're doing colbert
it's like we're sending a cover nurse
we're gonna take care of you you do
joey's pockets you're gonna get drugged
right more people might listen to this
oh yeah crazy good question that's crazy
this guy's kidnapped a person
we went on a field trip once in
milwaukee and we went we went downtown
and we're at a stoplight and this is
like winter in milwaukee
and there's this
look like maybe like a 19 to 20 year old
black dude skinny black just stand at
the corner and we're all like sitting in
the windows we're in like sixth grade
we're like
and he just pulls his pants down takes
his dick and wags it at us all
shook it like that
like you had some extra drops in it
and we were all like
the bus takes off
we were like t-shirts
miss harlan like it was the craziest i
mean it was definitely still one of the
biggest dicks i've ever seen right i'll
bet i'll bet he knew it too he knew what
he was just gonna be decades
i'll just kick her out
[__] right here
almost people love to show you
and he weighs his dick
my first day on that job by the way my
first day
on the america's most wanted as a as a
full employee is september 10 2001.
in dc
so i'm like my next my second day of
going to work is 9 11
right and like and and so then our whole
the whole show becomes like profiling we
we just profiled bin laden every day
still looking for him and i'm like at
the white house you know what cause
we're doing pressers from like you know
whatever they talk all they would talk
about is terrorism so then they would
send our crew to the white house so i
would just be sitting on the lawn you
know that west wing launches out there
calling friends like i'm at the [__]
white house and then flexing on people
people would be like you know they can
hear you right i was like yeah like i'm
just like yeah dude this place is
[__] awesome where are you guys
drinking that
this guy's a cop i don't trust him did
boomer ever get that weed what's the
deal
[Laughter]
tell me a joke just to you is not the
thing nothing
can you sit down yeah
you have to work it out in front of you
how much time do you have yeah for your
job but sometimes it takes me a while to
get there you know my dad talked me to a
lot he goes i want you to go to
lunch with my friend today yeah this was
like a couple years like okay
the guy was in his 80s okay which is
fine but so the guy goes like
immediately sit down he's like i got one
for you like i mean i go what one what
he's like so a guy walks into a bar
right and he starts telling me these
like street jokes and i'm like giving
like polite that's a much older man
he goes now you go
and i go what he goes tell me some of
yours
and i go oh i don't
i don't have jokes like that he goes
what the hell do you do up there
your dad said you're a comedian and i
was like they're longer and he's like
okay tell me one i go it's not it's not
gonna work man
and he's like what the [__] did you do
it though no
the only time i ever did that was with
the worst experience of my life
was i did a call-in one time to radio i
remember in in baltimore yeah and i had
a show coming up and the guy's like oh
you're going to be at the club and
he's like all right let's hear something
and i go ah nah
yeah he's like just give me one
and i go
nah he's like
go ahead give it to us give us give us a
little taste
and i was like
okay
and i just started doing
like a bit like i just went into a bit
yeah and it ended and he was like
okay
and i just i was sitting there in my
hotel room like this
like i want to die and then
i hung up
and then people started to message me
they're like you're getting ripped apart
by this radio guy right now like as
being an absolute piece of [__]
i was like he knew what he was doing we
[__]
we spent our lives hating these regional
radio douchebags yeah and i just can't
believe we're all radio guys now we are
we are we are we're all we're all radio
guys had a bigger dick and they go
when they're when their dicks showing
they go you know it gets bigger i always
tell people you know it gets smaller
because
i'll see my dick
at a stage that i think is small and
then later i'm like what the [__]
happened to that like it'll go further
up inside of me
if i do like
any type of
any type of like
exercise any cardio or something
it'll like invert itself
and i have to but it grows like a
thousand percent yeah that's good yeah
but i have to say the other day i walked
in on you and you were showering and you
turned around and i was like damn like
you had a really good hang and yeah
because there's like there's days and
there's moments and you know like how do
you think that is
i don't know i mean
you know it could be like that day that
you came in the shower or saw me i
probably
a hadn't ejaculated in like four days or
something wow um and then i i um i
wasn't scared i was
i was warm there was warm water in the
shower yeah you know all the like the
moon and everything aligned it's scary
yeah yeah does i haven't i fear fear
will do it fear makes you look like
everything your body will go in i mean
it doesn't mean that it happens to
everybody but it's a like men
in like if you are actually in fear like
your testicles and everything will come
in closer right and your body is like um
like what's it called like
saving mechanism where it's like protect
yourself yeah so for me like yeah i
remember one time we had these movers
come in and dude had like i was like
making sure that uh we were like in a
bad neighborhood dude's all like tatted
on the neck and stuff and i pulled her
aside i go my dick's so small right now
because i was like watching these guys
go through our house
okay
my dicks are small right yeah what are
we that's what you wanted to let her
know not to watch these guys but
i mean we had like you know
for then it was like minivans and like
like 16-hour drives you know to like
orlando jeez and that was the the
vacation
you would drive from like minneapolis
down there yes it was all [__] yeah
they never [__]
flew i mean did your mom drive or did
your dad have to bite that bullet no
really that woman is peruvian dude
no
she won't drive on the highway
still she's like the highway scares me
it moves too fast yeah she drives like
on side streets and then she's like will
you get me a car i'm like for what yeah
she also is like always asking for like
the newest laptop i'm like you play
bridge
like just use a [__] dell and she's
like you don't get it she's like i want
the new macbook air and i'm like why she
flexible
so much capacity no i get of course like
she guilts me into getting it for i got
her a [__] mercedes get her don't get
her an old game boy yeah i got her
mercedes
three months ago nice and she calls me
and she's like the problem is it's too
high it's like it's an suv
yeah that's how they make it
and she's like uh i get a low rider
she's like i need to ask if they can put
a climbing device on
a ladder like what are you talking about
and she's like maybe i switch it for
another one i go that's on you i'm done
i'm out yeah i you you switch it for
another car holy [__] yeah that's
[__] wild man did she she didn't work
growing up no did your dad speak spanish
[__] no she couldn't so she taught the
girl your sisters they spoke spanish too
well what happened was she just like
when she got to the like when they
married i'm like what kind of
relationship did you guys have she knew
how to say like 11 words
and they're like we had god you know
like they're both catholic
so they um they would just i mean i just
i didn't understand like how the [__]
this happened so as a kid
when she was like at home talking to us
meaning the three kids uh-huh she would
just speak in spanish spanish always
whether it's like to clean your room or
it's time to eat or you're late for
school or it was just all spanish
spanish spanish and then we would
usually reply in english right so it was
like right all right
but to my dad
you know she spoke never learned spanish
he knew like [__]
nine words like he'd be like tango i'm
breaking
one time i go i go i'm right yeah i go
you didn't i have hunger right i didn't
learn any like cool [__] and then this
is like right before he died he died
like in december this is probably like
in october september so he's never said
this to me i'm like
you never like she never taught you
anything and like she's sitting next to
him and he's like well there is one and
i go what and he said
which is my lit my mouth drops open for
your [__] i was like
how about where's the beach
that's what you [__] that's the only
that's great i go you only how why'd you
hold on to that well now you know how
relationships were you know what the
[__] was going on before it became legal
here yeah i was [__] i would you know
when you first moved to l.a friends
visit you there's like four places you
should see this yeah yeah right so i
take them on pch yeah and we go we're at
we're in
in malibu and
there are cars parked all up and down
pch right and i find a gap and i park
i'm one of a hundred cars yeah
he's in the passenger seat and he goes
you want to smoke a bowl before we get
going to the beach and i go i'm good he
goes all right i'm going to i was like
okay yeah so he he smokes
and then
a
california highway patrol guy passes us
this way and then he does a u-turn
and i'm like oh that's interesting and i
see him come around and then he pulls up
in front so this guy had just smoked
right there's no smoke in the car
anymore but obviously it smells
he gets out of the car and walks up to
my car and he goes you can't park here
and i was like
there's like 200 cars parked here
he goes yeah they're all illegally
parked i could tow every car here i was
like are you gonna
and he was like you just you can't park
here and i go okay just you just just
you
and i'm like all right man and he goes
so uh who's smoking
he just says it like that who's smoking
and i'm trying to not like throw him
under but thinking that since i'm
driving he's gonna so i just i kind of
go like
i look at him
and my friend goes nobody here
sir he goes he's the pro yeah he's like
he goes get out of the [__] car
and i'm like what he goes you think i
can't smell that yeah and i was like and
i'm just looking at my friend you
[__] dip [__] like just say something
so then he takes me and he puts me in
the back of his car oh my god and he's
like full treatment the full treatment
yeah he's like he goes where is it and i
go i go i really don't no it's not mine
yeah i'm not even saying it's his i'm
just like it's not mine and i don't know
where it is yeah and he goes okay we're
gonna play this game boom shuts the door
i was like [__] man
he takes him out of the car it's a black
car yeah he's shirtless because he has
to go to the ocean cuffs them and lays
them bare chested on the black car right
like in the heat yeah my friend's like
ah
i could hear him he's like [__] it's hot
and i see him talking to him and he
comes back to me he goes your friend
says it's yours and i go
i go it's not what are you talking about
man he just
yeah well i know i don't think he's said
that i think he's trying to oh he's
playing that game yeah playing the game
yeah trying to find it it's yours and
i'm like it's not i don't have the guy
in the car the guy cuffed on the car
didn't talk yeah yeah he's trying to wow
yeah he goes all right he goes uh he
comes back he goes i got it
um it's your car so it's yours and i was
like
and i get so nervous right i'm scared
i'm like yeah i go is there anything i
can do he goes what and i go dude i
swear to god i go almost i go i'll mow
your lawn
he's like what i go i'll mow your lawn
for a year and he's like you'll mow my
lawn and i'm like to not be in trouble
he's like no
and i'm like okay
so
that was all you had yeah i didn't know
what to say i was like i thought that
was a very nice offer
you have clean your lawn yeah we can't
negotiate it yeah man let's work this
out and so then he he opens the door he
lets me out he goes
you're getting the ticket
i'm like [__] and i'm thinking i'm going
to jail you're going to jail and he's
like no you get a ticket and i'm going
to tow your car and i was like where and
he's like to one of these like places
here and i go why he goes just to make
it like difficult on you and i was like
okay
and
he's like he's like so just wait here
for the tow truck yeah and then you'll
just go there and then you'll have to
pay for that too and get that out and i
was like just to like [__] up my day and
he was like right what is your take by
the way your gut reaction is this
horrible or hilarious oh
you're sick inside too if he's okay it's
hilarious he's not okay
yeah i see a smile from you the sound of
him yelling
that's funny
the sounds are funny
also the ting
the thing
that's funny yeah
here's a look at this slo-mo oh
oh oh that's not good
[__] oh
i remember one time
a small audience and a lady there was
like a table of 12 and that was like 85
of the audience and i'm like just like
two minutes in where you're like you
know
engaging feeling things out just kind of
like throwing things out she goes come
on
[Laughter]
snapped yeah
and then
they leave
and then the next day the owner's like
did you
call a lady a [__]
and like one i go i don't think it went
like that when i was in hartford yeah i
was doing this piece of [__] radio show
in a piece of [__] building
and they're just like oh i remember like
they had like the [__] oldest board
looked like the first year aboard came
out yeah these rickety mics and they're
like oh sit over here like to wait and
they just had me sit like
there yeah i was like yeah is this the
waiting room yeah and then they're like
all right we're gonna come out of this
break and then
just take over and i go what do you mean
yeah he's like just do like
you know it's your time to shine and i
go
what are you gonna ask and he was like
what what do you mean he's like just do
whatever you want to do i was like i
don't really want to do anything
and he goes
well no man we have like 30 seconds and
i go okay but i mean when you say take
over you mean like i run the segment
he's like if you want to yeah and i go
he goes man last week bobby lee was here
he got naked and i go how'd that work on
radio
and he's like what i go did it play to
the people listening in their cars
and he was like uh look man just do what
you want to do and i was like just ask
me some questions man he was so nervous
he was like oh my god and he pulled up
my bio yeah and i had a fake bio yeah
like as a joke he's like so you were in
the nfl and i was like yeah man
oh
six seasons and he was
420 bro
you